how far down does it go Disney's Strange
World features one talented and
star-studded cast this is everything you
need to know about the voices behind
Strange World number one you definitely
know his voice perhaps you remember Jake
Gyllenhaal from the cult classic Donnie
Darko or else you may know him from his
more romantic role in Love and Other
Drugs Gyllenhaal has also portrayed the
villainous Mysterio in Spider-Man far
from home strange World marks
Gyllenhaal's second animated movie as
you may have heard his voice if you
happened to watch 2021's Spirit Untamed
you like strawberries right this time
around Gyllenhaal plays searcherclade a
lovable farmer sent on a daring
Adventure alongside his family how are
you my dad Gyllenhaal has spoken about
how it was precisely that family aspect
that first Drew him to the script as
well as enjoying the freedom that the
cast had been afforded we'd be able to
play and explore and bring our own ideas
number two Gabrielle Union is one busy
woman
hey hey stop pushing buttons Millennials
in particular will remember Union from
some of our favorite teen films like
she's all that 10 Things I Hate About
You and bring it on strange world has
Union playing Meridian clade a pilot and
wife to search her clade what watch out
when discussing Strange World with
Cinema Blend Union celebrated the film's
representation of family stating it's
important to really showcase all kinds
of families and this is another
Perfectly Imperfect classic Disney
family that was important to us right we
wanted this movie to reflect the global
audience number three she dazzles on the
Silver Screen and in the sound booth did
you miss me you probably know Lucy Liu
from her breakout role as one of
Charlie's Angels in both 2000 and 2003
but she's also proven herself to have
some serious skill when it comes to
voice acting maybe you're already aware
of her work as Master Viper on the Kung
Fu Panda series do you really think Poe
can Master chi in time or else you may
even recognize her as Silvermist from
Disney's animated Tinkerbell series get
out of the way I show no mercy in
Strange World Lucy Liu has been cast as
the president of avalonia but avalonia's
future depends on us find out when
discussing what it was that she
appreciated most about the script she
said that she loved the amount of
Freedom that working within a futuristic
setting allowed for her character I
liked being a part of that world without
explanation or Exposition number four
you'd probably know this actor for his
face more than his voice Dennis Quaid
got his start as an actor in the 1980s
starring in Unforgettable cult classics
such as Innerspace and the right stuff
he starred alongside Lindsay Lohan in
The Parent Trap and appeared in GI Joe
the Rise of Cobra but outside of a very
brief appearance on SpongeBob
SquarePants he is mostly stuck to live
action roles strange world has Dennis
Quaid portraying Jaeger clade searcher's
father classic Jager claimed Quaid has
admitted that he was especially drawn to
strange World's theme of Legacy stating
this movie is about being yourself and
not what people think you should be or
something outside of that and that's the
way you're going to make the best
contribution to the world they're really
just going for authentic emotion and
within an authentic Story number five
jabuki young white is a rising star do
you mind if I call you splat he first
started performing stand up at the age
of 19. before going on to write for big
mouth and American Vandal in 2018 he was
hired as a correspondent for The Daily
Show opposite Trevor Noah this led to
his first starring role in the 2021 film
dating and New York as well as a
recurring role on only murders in the
building you may have already heard his
voice on the Disney plus animated series
Baymax playing mabita no it is not a big
deal but strange world has to launch him
to an entirely new audience here he
plays Ethan clade searcher's 16 year old
son this place is so crazy young white
was especially impressed to notice
certain similarities between himself and
his character stating it's like
bigger than I am and it's gorgeous
number six Alan Tudyk has become
Disney's go-to guy you might have seen
his face in such cult classics as
Firefly dodgeball and Tucker and Dale vs
Evil but he's since gone on to have an
established career as a voice actor
outside of Disney Alan tudick serves as
the voice for the Joker and Clayface on
HBO's animated Harley Quinn series but
it's his work with Disney over the last
decade that's truly proven his skills as
an actor tudik provides the voice for
the villainous King Candy in Wreck-It
Ralph the pacify this monster so we can
see what we're up against is as well as
the Droid k2so in Star Wars Rogue one
he's proven himself to be surprisingly
skilled when it comes to providing the
voices for animated animals playing Pico
the toucan in Kanto and tuk-tuk in Raya
and The Last Dragon Alan tudik has taken
on three roles for Strange World playing
a pilot named duffel no I'm just messing
with you and providing the voice for the
narrator and radio host one one proving
his range as a voice actor yet again I
always like playing
funny roles number seven we doubt you'd
be familiar with Jonathan malo's work
yet he's a bit of an unknown Talent
although he did appear as Theo's
handsome Stranger in American Horror
Story and as bank robber number two on
season 6 episode 17 of Blue Bloods
Strange World marks Jonathan malo's very
first appearance in a major motion
picture and we imagine that he must be
pretty excited to be joining such a
talented group of actors Melo has been
cast as Ethan's love interest although
that doesn't necessarily mean that the
two spent much time together on set
number eight Karen Sony has become one
familiar face so cute I want to
merchandise there you would probably
know him best for his absolutely
hilarious and surprisingly endearing
performance as dopinder in both Deadpool
and Deadpool 2. you're my Tom Cruise and
you're my Kristen Dunst but that's far
from his only role he's gone on to prove
his comedic chops in office Christmas
party and the 2016 remake to Ghostbuster
clusters although he's proven
entertaining in live action he's also
come to be very familiar with the sound
booth karon also voices a character for
the Netflix series Karma world and he
has taken on the role of Riff across the
trolls franchise in Strange World Sony
plays Caspian an outspoken Adventurer
who's a huge fan of Dennis Quaid's
character Jaeger clade I'm a huge fan
thank you of your dad number 9. Adelina
Anthony is a triple threat between their
acting directing and writing project
there are a number of ways you may be
familiar with this talented filmmaker
they have produced a number of their own
films when it comes to their on-screen
appearances you may recognize Anthony
for their role as Rocky on Vita although
they have also appeared on a single
episode of Walker Texas Ranger as Maria
Alonso when you're watching strange
World make sure to keep an eye out for
Adelina taking on the role of Captain
Polk on the spaceship's crew number 10
Abraham Ben Ruby might be better known
for his voice than his face although his
performance as Jerry on the ER proved
his ability in front of the camera then
Ruby is very comfortable in a sound
booth he's provided a number of voices
for the animated comedy series Robot
Chicken created by his close and
personal friend Seth Green Ben Ruby's
voice would also be familiar to you if
you're a gamer too as he's done
additional voices for World of Warcraft
and Diablo 3. Strange World cast Abraham
as Lonnie Redshirt whose name is a clear
joke on Star Trek's Redshirt Trope with
its cast built on both familiar faces as
well as some strongly established voice
actors strange world is sure turning out
to be one legendary journey you won't
soon forget